Aww yeah! Today we have a special lesson with friends featuring guest star Brad Pitt.
So it was just Thanksgiving and this is a holiday that is celebrated by virtually all Americans,
in which we come together with friends and family and have a big feast while we reflect on things
that we are grateful for over the past year.
An American series like Friends often do special episodes with these kind of holidays
which makes them a great resource not only to improve your English, but also to learn about American culture,
so we're going to jump into the lesson
in just a sec.
But just in case you're new here I want to let you know that every single week we make fun lessons like this one
so that you can understand fast speaking natives without getting lost,
without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles,
just like TaeTae who says that thanks to our lessons, they can now speak confidently with natives
and you can too,
all you have to do is hit that subscribe button
and the bell down below so you don't miss
any of our new lessons
and finally I just wanted to let you know that we have a special present to go along with this video.
It is this PDF Power Lesson which you can download and is going to help you to take your knowledge with this
scene to the next level so that you don't forget anything that you learned today.
You can download that down in the description below.
So now let's roll this scene a with Brad Pitt on a friend.
So I really cannot express to you just how thankful
we are to have over 1.25 million
subscribers from every corner of the globe
To show a bit of our gratitude I
want to let you know that for the next
48 hours we have a special sale going on
on our fluent with friends course.
In this 48-week course you will
learn like never before as you follow
along with the first two seasons of the
series Friends.
Plus you get 20 plus page PDF Power Lessons, vocabulary memorization software,
access to our Fluency Circle global community,
and so much more.
So for Black Friday we have a tremendous 33 percent discount available to you on all the packages
of our course.
This is really going to help
you in reaching your goals to
confidently understand natives
and improve your fluency
so you can learn a ton more
about this course by clicking the link
up here or down in the description below
and remember to get your discount just
use the coupon code THANK YOU at checkout
and remember you have your PDF Power Lesson
that you can download for
this lesson and this is actually one of
the resources that you get with the
Fluent with Friends course.
However, it is for the full episodes.
You will also find the link to that down in the description below
and now let's get back to the lesson.
is coming Ross has come great I love
Ross to mean in this case means to have
Hey so you can discover a lot more about the American holiday of Thanksgiving
and learn eleven native ways to say thank you in this
lesson after you finish this video.
So THANK YOU again for all of your support.
We are just so proud to see we've been
able to help so many of you with these fun lessons.
and remember if you want to
get that tremendous 33 percent discount
on our Fluent with Friends course thenyou have to use the coupon code THANK YOU before December 1st.
and do you want to know what happens next
in today's scene
well we have an old lesson
where we see the conclusion of
this hilarious scene with Brad Pitt on
friends that you can check out here
and you might also like these other lessons
teaching you English with Brad Pitt and
now it's time to go beyond the classroom
and live your English
Aww yeah!